Most Spaniards
that reject the Spanish flag
usually use the same argument
the flag does not represent me
because the right wing has appropriated it
And I think it is
precisely when it is not in the USA
when you are trying to get the flag to acquire 1
ideological I give you 1 example
Real Madrid
The ultrasur are Real Madrid's ultras
and you all know its marked political ideology
They always wore several symbols
when they were going to the Bernabeu
and among them
of course
was Madrid's grandfather
If the rest of madridismo
who did not sympathize with the ultrasur
would have stopped wearing the under the argument
is that the ultras have appropriated it then
Today with El Paso de los años
Madrid's Argentine would have
probably political connotations
but as ultras and not ultras they used it equally.
remained as everyone's reflection
Another example
dress with vest Why is it called fa vest
Because it is that everything is used by right-wing people.
with money but if everyone was dressed
from time to time with vest
they would stop calling it fa vest
The same happens with the Spanish flag
How nice it would be
to see it at rallies of right-wing parties
and at rallies of left-wing parties
equally,
regardless of their ideology
Because if everyone used it
in a very short time
would lose its political connotations
and everyone could wear it without any problem
and Seriously and for me it is
the flag of all
that of 1 motherfucker country